[Applause]
welcome back to the social if your New
Year's resolution is to make some
positive changes in your life there's a
lot to consider like what's the best way
to get noticed by your boss and when
should you ask for a promotion all good
questions so here to tell us what we
need to know to get ahead in the
workplace is ctv's financial
correspondent also star of that little
old show on ctv2 Shark Tank Kevin o is
here welcome back
welcome back thank you I love this show
and I'm always looking for the single
guy in the audience where we right over
there right
there so Kevin how do you know your
worth I mean is there a hard fast way to
calculate your value to a company well
what matters when you're working for a
company is can you execute the task
given to you in other words in a large
corporation even a small one somebody
says look this is a job that has to get
done we're giving it to you and then
what matters is do you get it done A and
B how fast do you get it done and how
much ripple effect as I call it do you
cause can you work with others maybe not
do you cause a lot of hassle on others
to get your job done these are the
metrics by which employees are measured
but number one is execution of the task
you can take a lot of pain from somebody
that's socially inept perhaps doesn't
work with others well but when they get
the job done that's pure
gold that's what matters okay can you
let your work speak for itself or should
you be uh bragging about your
accomplishments to your boss very
dangerous to brag really dangerous
because you know what what keeps you
employed is having your boss look great
and when all of a sudden you try and
bragging is often perceived by a
superior as you trying to pass them on
the freeway to the top of the company
not a good look not a good and so you
cause yourself a lot of grief when you
do that you've got to be a politician
when you're an employee you've got to
understand when to take and when to give
and what to say and what not to say
making your boss look good is always a
good path even if your boss is a
bad you know they call them boss holes
yes and so because eventually whoever is
the superior of the boss hole gets rid
of them but looks at you as gold because
you helped that boss achieve their goals
that were had to be achieved I find
great employees are ones that know they
have to get their job done don't make a
lot of noise doing it but everybody
start
understand that they know what they're
doing and they naturally rise up like
cream to the top that's what happens
just get your work done stop whining
about it just do it and good things will
happen to you it's that simple what if
you think you deserve a promotion ah so
there's two ways to go about that um
bosses are often ready for you to come
at them in January at the beginning of a
year with a new budget in place
particularly in big companies to sit
down and say look we're going to do a
review of you from last year which
generally is part of the process yeah
what's good what's bad about you what
you did well what you didn't that's the
time to say listen I think I did a great
job we've just recognized it in my
review if it did go well I'd like you to
give me a raise I'm looking for let's
say 5 to 7% generally they're already
ready for that now in the middle of a
year there's another tactic that works
because this happens to me and all my
companies let's say there's a big
opportunity let's say one of your
companies gets a new client and they're
huge and there's a huge amount of work
to get done and it's got to be done in a
short period of time step up to the
plate go to your boss and say look I can
do this for you I can make this happen I
can achieve the goal but I want
recognition if I pull it off let's talk
about what you're going to do for me if
I make this work for you I know it's
July I'm going to you know trim my
holiday back or work extra hard if I get
it done I want a raise now or I want a
bonus or I want some Showmanship of
appreciation for why I'm doing this for
you
believe you can do it they'll pay
anything to get it done that's I've done
that many many times saying look this
doesn't even include your bonus next
year this is a one-time fee you get this
done I'll give you $10,000 and I've paid
that many times and that gets the EMP I
like the way you operate oh yeah listen
you know you go to work to make money
it's not there to make friendships I
mean it's great that you can do that
within a with a within a business but
you're there to achieve economic success
for the organization so you stay
employed and I think what's what really
matters is great employee
are perceived as gold to their bosses
they'll do anything to keep them happy
because it makes their jobs easier it's
just like a big beehive all humming
together now when you're a bad bee you
end up on the ground
outside that's what happens you always
kill animal an allergies when you come
here it's better than talking about
killing people right I guess so so
you're mentioning this the whole idea of
interpersonal and Inter office
relationships as well so if you notice
that an employee works better alone than
as part of a group for example you
mentioned this off the top will that
hurt their chances at success it can in
some cases but today in a very
technology driven Society there's often
places where you know individuals that
work well by themselves can find a good
niche in a company for example if you're
a computer
programmer you're from another planet
anyways you know and and those people
work very well by themselves they're
given goals sometimes they work 24/7
sometimes they take a couple of days off
I've got guys that write code for me I
don't care if they show up as long as
the code is written on time they live in
their own world that's different than
working in a highly social environment
like fashion for example you've got to
deal with people you have to communicate
with them you have to be liked or often
not you know let's think about it that's
different but there's places for people
that are it inept socially you can find
a job as long as you can execute I don't
worry about you know making friends if
you can get your job done that's all
that matters okay but you often hear
saying like dress for the job that you
want not the one that you have or dress
for success does attire and the way you
present yourself is that making an
impact on your manager yes not your
manager because you don't have a manager
you are the manager
and I serve my shareholders I'm always
raising capital for my companies I
always wear a tie when I talk about
money the answer to that is yes yes yes
and yes you have to
dress appropriately you know you think
about going into a bank or a financial
institution or an insurance company or a
large corporation
and you wear the same thing you wore
Saturday night at a club I don't think
so that's a bad outcome if people are
looking at you because you look hot
that's a bad outcome you have to look
appropriate then
there you know I'm not kidding this is
this is a very T and most companies now
have written policies regarding what
you're wearing when you're a man or a
woman there's there's a there's a Code
of ethic regarding dressing and I think
it's important I've always been a big
advocate for for getting a good wardrobe
so that you have the appropriate
clothing for your work environment and
your boss notices it too you know if you
look sharp and clients look at you
well-dressed that's very good and so
that's an investment in yourself you can
buy very appropriate clothing in
expensively if you don't know how to do
that get some advice because if you show
up with the wrong stuff that's an
impression that never leaves people
remember it for a very long time you
want wardrobe that people don't notice
because it's great all the time yeah if
someone doesn't remember what you wore
yesterday that's good I'm not kidding
that's really good now let me ask you
mentioned at the beginning of the show
we're always looking for the single man
in the audience because a lot of women
watch this show so we all know it's
common knowledge that um women are
underrepresented in leadership positions
in business and in politics so Kevin
what needs to happen to change so that
women are promoted into leadership roles
well the good news is it is happening
you can find the chairmanship of banks
take RBC for example the chairman
the head of that whole bank is a woman
now and what's happened is boards and
large companies have realized that you
know it's important to bring women into
the board or into management because
they're very valid their opinions are
important I look at my own world o funds
my best investors are women they're very
pragmatic the companies I back I've got
three companies now run with women CEOs
that have been phenomenal successes
they're focused they don't take huge
risks they understand the goal at hand
there's lots of evidence that women are
very very equal in terms of providing
the task in business and I think our
society particular in Canada now is very
open we're saying look let let any woman
that wants to rise to the top because
it's good for business it's not you
trying to get people to take these
things on because you feel it has a
social or moral aspect to it is not as
powerful as performance metrics and
there's many women look at you ladies
here you have your own show I don't see
any guy hosts here this is this is
success
so and by the way all of our bosses are
female too yes in television there's
lots of female Executives but the reason
you're still on the air is the show's a
hit advertisers want to advertise people
come to watch it it works it's not
because you're women it's because you've
achieved success in business that's
what's happening here so that means like
a $10,000 bonus each for us
right I'll put a I'll put in a good word
to the boss for a thank you so much
Kevin for your great advice always don't
forget to tune in to Shark Tank Fridays
at 9:00 P p.m. Eastern on CTV 2 we'll be
right back after the short break I'm
still
here